[Musique]
comment déterminer la fiabilité d'un
site web de nouvelles d'actualité le
contenu de sites prétendument
d'actualité leboeuf nos chroniques au
basée aux états unis a récemment subi
une certaine confusion dans le contexte
de notre campagne électorale fédérale
une quantité considérable d'articles sur
la politique canadienne ont été publiées
dont une bonne partie a été démentie on
a tous eu à faire à notre insu ou non à
des sites de nouvelles à la fiabilité
disions douteuses alors comment on fait
pour évaluer la fiabilité d'un site web
d'actualité
voici en rafale quelques astuces conseil
numéro un
porter une attention particulière à
l'adresse du site web
pourquoi mais parce que les faux sites
tentent souvent de nous induire en
erreur en utilisant une url une adresse
web similaire à celle des vrais sites
retenez aussi qu'une simple lettre
manquante dans l'adresse d'un site web
le place dans la catégorie défaut site
conseil numéro 2 jetez un coup d'oeil à
la section à propos du site web sur
lequel vous avez des doutes
un site d'information sérieux donnent
souvent dans cette section
plus d'informations sur ces têtes
dirigeantes sa mission sa démarche et
les normes qu'il se fixe si ces
informations sont manquantes
méfiez-vous conseil numéro 3 vérifier
les sources des citations et le profil
de l'auteur
normalement un texte devrait s'appuyer
entre autres sur des citations
si les citations sont inexistantes nos
diversifier ou si aucune information
vous permet d'en valider l'origine d'un
gang et sous roche
coucou pire encore certains articles
fallacieux n'indique parfois même pas
qui en est l'auteur et si le nom de
l'auteur apparaît tout comme sur les
personnes citées à une petite recherche
est de mise
conseil numéro 4 vérifier l'authenticité
des images publiées
parce que bien souvent des sites
trompeur utilise des images tout aussi
trompeuse sortis de leur contexte
original ou carrément intérêts donc une
simple recherche d'image inversée peut
vous éclairer sur l'authenticité de
l'image conseil numéro 5 vérifier si le
site est ouvertement satirique certains
faux sites d'actualités s'affiche
clairement comme étant satirique pour ne
pas qu'on les prennent trop au sérieux
et qu'on sait numéro 6 pas le temps
d'appliquer tous ces conseils il existe
rassurez-vous des sites web comme muse
garde qui font ce type de vérification
sur une base régulière et et même une
extension de news gags qui peut être
installée sur votre barre de navigation
et des icônes comme celle ci vous
indiqueront jusqu'à quel point le site
consulté et crédibles ou non mais le
conseil qui devrait toujours primer
variés tout simplement vos sources
d'informations et comparer
[Musique]